Suicide Squad is coming in the trailers
character sneak peeks and terrible awful
Joker quotes are ramping up I'm Kate and
this is your butt kicking news update a
new trailer for Suicide Squad was
released tonight at the MTV Movie Awards
the video showcases the unlikely band of
villains who come together to do good or
something like that in addition to
villains like the Joker and Harley Quinn
we also see Batman and the Batmobile
Suicide Squad is directed by Furies
David ayah and tells the story of a
group of death row super villains who
are employed covertly by the US
government to perform dangerous missions
it stars jared leto as joker alongside
Will Smith as dead shot and Margot
Robbie as Harley Quinn we recently
learned that reshoots did indeed take
place but they were not done to make the
film funnier as an earlier report had
suggested instead Warner Bros went back
to add more action according to
boomerang actor Jai Courtney last month
it was rumored that even though the film
doesn't open till August a sequel was
already in development varieties Justin
crawl reported that he had been hearing
for a while the studio wants the sequel
up as quickly as possible and that they
also want all players back including aya
are you convinced by suicide squad yet
or do you think it's another superhero
flop let me know in the comments or come
and find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot